هل هو واقع الحال ام درب من خيال لا يتفق
ولا يتفق مع ذات الاردنيين ولا مع حياتهم
وربما الفاظهم ومفرداتهم من هنا بدات نقطه
الخلاف حول فيلم الحاره احداث الفيلم تدور
في احدى حالات الاردن وتسلط الضوء على
تفاصيل حياه اهلها كجزء من المجتمع يعاني
الكثير طرح جاء من الواقع لكن المستعجنه
كان الفاظا لم تتقبلها مسامع المشاهدين من
خلال الدراما الاردني حتى لو كان في من
مجتمعنا هيك فئه المفروض يحاربوها ما
يعرضوها او يخلوها شيء طبيعي يعني انه
بحجه والله انه في من مجتمعنا ناس بتحكي
بهذه الالفاظ لا من عاداتنا ولا من شيمنا
ولا من اللي علمونا اياه جدودنا ولا شيء
من كل هذا الحقيقه يعني هسه لو جدي وجدك
عايشين اللي بيحضروا هيك اشياء يمكن
يذبحونه بصراحه
ما فيها هذيك الالفاظ يعني في المواقع
بتصور ما في شيء
الى قبه البرلمان حيث انقسمت المطالبات ما
بين سحب الفيلم وايقاف عرضه وصولا الى سحب
الجنسيه من الفنان منذر رياحنا لتبريره
بان الفيلم مراه تعكس واقعا حقيقيا اضافه
لمطالبتهم برفع دعوه قضائيه ضده لاساءته
للهويه الاردنيه